we talk about uh choosing the quote
characters
um let's suppose they aren't a big name
but they're very interesting people that
have a story that's going to go
somewhere
right who are you choosing the ones you
know will bring the most conflict
the most fascinating to watch you're
looking for
i talked about casting for conflict
where you have
personalities that are a little bit
different that you assume that they
might rub up against each other in the
wrong way
i think it's also important to have
when you cast people to bring their
friends in so that they have a confidant
or someone that they can get away to
there can't if i did a show and it was
just you and me
we they would be a terrible show and the
reason why is because
everything that either one of us said
would be taken at absolute face value
if i have my best friend you and i can
have a conversation and then i can go to
a scene where i just
say listen i just had this interview and
they asked me all these terrible
questions about reality television and i
put on my brave face for her but i'm so
embarrassed and i'm so worried that this
is going to get cut funny
and i'm going to look like a or
that some old producer is going to see
it and think i'm talking about him
and then i have a scene and then i have
a show because now i have something to
worry about and
and i don't have to express every
thought that i have to you
so yeah there's casting for conflict but
you also need to make sure that you're
you're filling your cast and rounding it
out with characters who will support
each other
uh and and really just sort of be there
for the purposes of having those side
conversations
and you said earlier that it's very rare
that well maybe
more so now that you'll cast sort of the
everyday joe
off the street what are those characters
you said that someone that has a story
that's going to go someplace
so how do we know their story is
actually going to go someplace
well here's the thing if you're if
you're casting someone make sure that
that person has something that's going
on in their life
that they have a goal or a vision or an
objective for themselves
that they're at a transitional point in
their life that's really important to
follow
where you're anticipating change or
you're anticipating action to be
happening in your life
if i have two people together and one
person really wants to be on a reality
show
and she can play the guitar a little bit
and she has a dog
and the other person comes on and they
can play guitar a little bit and they
have a dog
but also they have this kind of weird
adversarial relationship with their
mother
who doesn't really want them to be a
singer because they don't think it's a
very good thing
all of a sudden that person becomes
three-dimensional and i start thinking
about
how are we going to get the mother into
it like how will we bring the mother
into the show
or the the the worry about what mom
thinks
and then i can see that going somewhere
over the course of a season
like that person might have to make a
decision later about whether or not she
can stay in la
because her mother's going to cut her
off and not support her and she might
have to go home and then you start
thinking about all the things that could
happen
or get a job or get a job you know i see
the most fascinating
emails come through from infolist for
you know i love to just reopen
looking for you know and and
what is it like being at one of those
casting
calls i mean i know it's whittled down
to many different
levels of it but i don't work a lot
directly with casting
most of the time the casting is done by
the time i get to the show
there are periods where i have
interacted with cast members before
they've been cast
to sort of suss out you know just give
by two cents as far as
who i think will work and who won't
to be in the room for those sorts of
castings
the best thing that you can do as a
producer
is to facilitate allowing that person to
be themselves
and that means be cordial
talk to them about things calm them down
be direct with them let them know that
when you're doing a reality show
that it's not just about us following
you that you know once in a while we may
ask you
specifically can you have a dinner with
this person and talk about a couple
things
sort of lay that groundwork because if
people aren't informed very well then
you have a very difficult
shoot period where you have two or three
weeks at the top
where people are just realizing that
this isn't what they thought it was
going to be
at those castings you have to really
prepare people for what the process is
so that they can make an informed
decision about being on the show
because if they're miserable they'll
clam up and if they clam up you've got
real problems
do you ever have plants in the room and
i'm not talking
palms and by plants in the room you mean
decoys people that are listening to see
if somebody's really that person or
are they when once they get in that
board i
i think that the people who do the best
jobs of casting reality shows
can pick a personality apart on their
own without any help
they really know how to judge a genuine
response
they really know when someone is the
person that they're coming to you
as you know what you don't want is the
guy that comes like hey i'm wild and i'm
crazy and whatever and then the cameras
turn
on and he's like i don't embarrass
myself
you don't want that and anybody who's
really good at casting has seen that
person a million times who could turn it
on
for an audition and just in an
inauthentic way and then just can't
possibly
sustain it for a period of eight to
twelve weeks while you shoot the show
you